obviously uh the pandemic but there's
been so much other heaviness
going on in the last month i know that
you've been
uh activist and a very active
activist for many many years and you
take this
very seriously and i'm just curious uh
are how have how the conversations been
in the wake of uh george
floyd's murder were you and your family
having
different conversations than you've had
before or
were you was it more was it more intense
or did you feel like
no this this didn't change anything for
us we've we've known this for a long
time
well we we've definitely had these
conversations before but i think
if everyone uh has felt
an intensity about this one and it has
been ratcheted up
um you know mainly because of the
callousness
and in the manner in which it was you
know
the murder happened and and how we were
all locked down
and just watching it on a loop i mean i
never saw the whole tape actually
i just saw the beginning and the end i
couldn't
really uh watch it um but yes these
conversations have
be have have been had prior to this with
my family with the community
but with my kids it was definitely
ratcheted up a lot more
because you know for them my youngest
anyway is really just sort of
getting into the workforce just you know
beginning her life
and really starting her life as an adult
out there and
having all of these things happen at the
same time you know
you know george floyd was after ahmad
arbory was after
brianna taylor was after even you know
amy cooper in the park
so i think the the confluence of all of
those things together
with the pandemic on top of it really
made
this sort of like you know boiling point
happen
and then you know we saw the lid come
off
and hopefully we will continue
to find ways to keep the conversation
alive i know that there's still you know
protests in
portland it's still happening all around
the country all around the world really
so it's not like people have completely
forgotten but you know
human beings want to exhale
they want to let that stress off and and
and go back to what they believe is
normal
but i just think we can't we can't do
that now because i think a return to
what is normal
is actually a step back it won't be just
a return it'll be a
it'll be a complete reset to something
that
i don't think we can afford to do as a
community so hopefully
this moment is instructive and hopefully
we'll find
many many different ways to continue
this conversation and find out how we
can
really approach this systematic issue
from all different angles
um there's a question i want to ask you
uh that that i've been pondering a
little bit
which is the role of celebrities in
all of this um
i think it can maybe sometimes get a
little complicated
with some degrees and and i i i think
you feel the same way but i thought
maybe we could have a discussion about
that
um my feeling being
there's a fine there's a very fine line
between
uh someone in the public eye giving of
themselves and trying to move
this piece forward and trying to help us
all grow
and saying hey look at me i'm
uh check me out it it can flip
so quickly and uh i just i
i just wanted to talk to you about it
because i'm sure you know you have a
a strong opinion about it well i agree
with what you're saying i mean it's
it can be a double-edged sword you know
we we have this platform
and and we're we're both
you know uh sensitive people and we are
are a part of the world and we
understand that we
uh though we have this ability to in
some ways
insulate ourselves from things at the
same time we are not insulated
and these these issues affect everyone
and so
yes we want to take our platforms and
find ways to be productive and find ways
that you say move this thing forward
but i think a lot of times what it
requires is for us
to kind of step out of the way and
use uh the power that we have as
producers
as people behind the cameras as well as
in front of the camera
to uh you know to push it on that end
and make sure that the non-centered
voices get centered
and make sure that the people who are
not seen uh
get to the front and you know something
that i saw people were doing on twitter
which i thought was really cool
a lot of people were just giving their
platform over to other people
you know you have a million followers
you're like okay now let's check out
debbie who's doing this with whatever or
jim who's doing this over here and
they're just gonna have my platform for
for a while
so i think a lot of times our best work
is done when we step
out of the way we get the attention and
then we shift the light you know shift
the focus
and and yeah it's tricky because you can
look like you're cloud surfing you can
look like you're trying to go
look at me but i'm cool with saying look
at me as long as once people are looking
at you you go now look at them
you know so right okay that's a that's a
great way
about that right that's a great way of
thinking of it
i i like that that that uh
because i'm always and i also think
it's be willing to try things
have them work not work but just move
move on
right it's that fear
that a lot of people have of making a
mistake or looking
uh silly that gets discussed a lot now
which is
try and if you make a mistake or if
someone if some of your friends check
you and say yeah that wasn't quite it
nice try but that wasn't quite it don't
overreact and get defensive
try again yeah fail fail better i mean
i'm i'm i'm
i'm not sure who's the quote is i had a
discussion with eddie escalade and if he
wants to
text in he can tell us but yeah i think
it's try fail
you know fail better just keep
you know just keep at it you can't it's
too important to dip out and especially
because you get
beat up on you know twitter or wherever
you know that's not that's not really
the the barometer by which we should be
judging
how we should be acting although i
understand it can be it can influence us
but we
just have to continue to ring the bell
and and like you said and sometimes it's
not the perfect way but you just got to
keep
bringing it yeah i always think uh
this has been something that's been this
issue has plagued our country for a
couple of hundred years it is the
defining uh you know stain on our
country that we
that we need to we need to get better we
need to resolve and so if some
embarrassment on twitter
is the price that you pay yeah so what
suck it up suck it up suck it up